well my next guest is from a sporting
Dynasty despite his father Barry Hearn
claiming his son was born with a silver
spoon Eddie Hearn has grown the family
business signing boxing's first billion
dollar deal become one of the sports
most recognizable faces around the world
including America but just how far will
the promoter go to follow the money
Saudi Arabia's so-called Sports watching
Empire is expanding across football
Formula One Golf and of course boxing
and there's now a reported one billion
dollar offer for Paris saint-germain's
killing mbappe should we be afraid of
the Saudi World takeover well I'm
delighted to say Eddie heard is joining
me live
uncensored in the studio welcome Eddie
good evening great to see you um
this whole Saudi thing has been
fascinating to me watching Live Gold for
example take on the PGM basically batter
the PGA into submission watching Formula
One embracing all the money from the
Middle East and then my friend Cristiano
Ronaldo going out to Saudi and really
transforming World football you look at
all the stars going there now following
Ronaldo as he said it could be the fifth
best league in the world within a year
it is extraordinary to watch
should we be concerned about this what's
your view of this Saudi domination of
World sport I mean we we first went
there in 2019 with Anthony Joshua
against Andy Ruiz in the rematch got a
lot of criticism obviously I don't like
to position boxing differently to goal
for tennis but it's prize fighting and
our job is to obviously maximize the
earnings of a fighter over a short
period of time what I've learned through
my work out there is you've got a lot of
passionate people about sport the
political argument of sports washing and
so forth now I don't want to push that
away and say I'm I you know that's not
my responsibility I don't see that as
much I see a group of people in charge
of certain sports that are ultimately
huge fans with a unparalleled budget and
people in boxing that have actually
worked amongst the Grassroots is up 300
for boxing clubs I think they've
quadrupled the number of amateur boxing
clubs Etc but it's just people in charge
who have a huge passion for a sport I
was there three or four weeks ago talk
in boxing in in you know in in Prince
khalid's house who runs the boxing
they're all watching football
unbelievable uh football fans well
Ronaldo told me that the the fans it's
incredible he said the stadiums are
packed out the fans go crazy they're
very knowledgeable the quality of the
football's better than he thought it was
and he's obviously massively improving
with all these signings you've got all
these top players going there's no doubt
they're on a mission to be very dominant
in the sport do you see a downside to
this or when you see in bad Bay
potentially going for one season if he
accepts this deal for a billion dollars
most people will think this is
completely insane they would see it as a
marketing play yeah I see I think we can
talk about it we can debate it we can
talk about the pros and cons but all of
it's irrelevant it's not going away
right this is a group of very determined
individuals who want to make Saudi
Arabia the Forefront of global Sport and
they have the budget to do it at every
single level and is there a lot of
hypocrisy the reason I asked to take
someone like Jordan Henderson who's just
gone to play in Saudi I remember at the
Qatar World Cup he said when we were
given the briefing on Qatar which is
really important it was shocking and
disappointing it's horrendous really
when you look at some of the issues
they're currently happening and have
been happening over there all sounds
great right to the point he then gets on
a plane and goes and plays in Saudi
Arabia he's put his morals to one side
and his concerns is there a lot of your
pocket I believe there is I think that
if you look at most countries around the
world us including you know we if you go
to a Qatar like I didn't talk to the
locals I said what about your illegal
invasion of Iraq who gives you the right
to put a Halo on your heads yeah and I
think every country has their problem
obviously Saudi Arabia perhaps more so
from a human rights issue but also
sometimes I return to this country and
look at the problems we have here right
and prefer to worry about that I think
when we talk about sport you know like I
said this isn't going away this is a
group of people that are very determined
to make an impact is it good or bad
let's be honest what I didn't like about
live particularly was the press
conferences that were held yeah where
people were talking and glorifying the
format and the change in you know in
structure moving from the PGA Tour to
lived let's just be completely honest
and by the way I don't blame these
people it's a huge amount of money that
will set them up their kids generations
for years and years Beyond who can
actually blame Ronaldo or mbappe for
taking a deal like that you can
celebrate ones that don't because of
other issues or because of you know a
moral principle but at the end of the
day in all business and sport is
business as well money talks and they're
not going to be able to reject this
amount of money over time why is money
not yet talked Anthony Joshua fighting
Tyson Fury
um I think it's a lot of things I think
Tyson Fury who
I'm saying he's slowly being found out
but he's not always as truthful as he
appears on Instagram timing is is
something I think television rights and
Partnerships are something
um Instagram is something ego is very
much somebody wants to see this
everybody wants to see it and on August
12th Anthony Joshua will fight dillian
white on the Zone after that he will
fight Deontay Wilder in Saudi Arabia and
then after that it has to be Tyson Fury
Tyson Fury turned down the Alexander
rusick fight the biggest fight really
the most important fight in boxing the
Undisputed Heavyweight World
Championship two fight an MMA fighter
who's never had a fight before in his
life also in Saudi Arabia we've got to
be honest Tyson Fury cares about one
thing only the money all right don't
talk to me about Legacy don't talk to me
about Undisputed don't talk to me about
it he has banned over everybody out
really who well who everybody out there
oh Wilder who your boys so he's been
Klitschko and Wilder that's his wins he
needs to be usick and AJ and then we can
talk about him as I believe he is as one
of the greatest heavyweights of all time
listen he's unbelievable what he's come
back from incredible couldn't commend
him more but to create a legacy to
create that history to go down as a
modern day great to put yourself up with
Ali with Lennox Lewis with Joe Frazier
those guys he's got to be usick and he's
got to be Anthony Joshua but
particularly USIC who's the Undisputed
Champion well I think he will be using
he'll fight him and beat him and then
the real fight I want to see is him and
Joshua everybody let's get through
dillian white first yeah
it's all about you because I
I got to know you and your dad we
holiday in the same place and uh I've
seen how competitive you are even at
play golf with each other you were
brought up in a very similar atmosphere
as a family to the one that I've tried
with my kids that my parents drive with
me where it was tough love you know like
No Quarter was given your dad wanted you
to be successful and he felt the best
way to do it was for example he put a
cricket net in your garden a bowl as
fast as he could he's a very good
cricketer and could ball quick when you
were like young kid 11 12 years old then
when he was 16 he'd been boxing for a
few years he said we're gonna have a
fight you and me in the ring and a pair
of you get in a ring and have a proper
match and first of all what happened in
that fight well you know I was a big kid
I mean I'm six foot five now but he
always said to me look you know you have
to understand it and people there was
there was an article in the garden
recently where the writer kind of failed
to understand
my child wasn't normal and as I get
older I realized more and more it
actually wasn't normal but it worked for
us my dad was from dagenham right the
one thing he hated more than anything
growing up was
a sport kid right a rich kid who had
everything and he was petrified that I
was going to be that kid so he drilled
into me work ethic working class
mentality you get given Nothing winning
is everything and I was brought up on
sport you know it was the one thing that
taught me discipline manners respect
winning losing of course physical health
mental health all of that stuff working
as a team and that's why I'm so
passionate about that for the next
Generation but you know he always said
to me when you get to 18 I'm going to
take you down to gym and I'm going to
give you a complete pasting he said
you're a soft Silver Spoon sport kid and
I'm from dagenham and I'm gonna you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna take you to school
so I said oh I understand and I boxed a
little bit you know I thought I was good
but I was terrible but I got to 16 and I
was already six foot I was 14 Stone he
said look we need to bring It Forward a
couple of years
because he was walking yeah I was a bit
of a lump so we went down to the Romford
boxing gym and there was Fighters down
there we put on these little gloves and
we got in the ring and the bell went
we're doing three two minute rounds and
a bell ring and I'll never forget
because he came at me and I've never
seen such determination and grit to
inflict damage on his own side yeah and
her teeth were great you know and he was
banging away and I was taking shots and
anyway beat me up for the first round
and in the second round he was
completely gone he's out of gas and I've
I've left up to the body took one knee
got up done him again and he was
counting it out and the next day it's in
every paper and he's told he couldn't
have been prouder you know normally if
your son gives you a bit of a posting
you'd sort of want to keep it a bit
quiet he was so proud that and how did
you feel
about the whole thing I knew you know
again he done a job on Me growing up you
know with the right mentality but you
know he was like you're one of us do you
know what I mean that's how he felt and
and the problem is is you know sport is
the answer for saying we were talking in
the you know in the green room so sport
is the answer for me totally for the
growth the education and molding I mean
I'm so mental health about the
resilience for all of it boxing in the
community now politicians the government
they don't go to these clubs now if you
go in there and see the types of kids
that are in these clubs and speak to
every fighter that exists and some of
them obviously are a bigger torch than
others Anthony Joshua great example got
in trouble with the police got arrested
stumbled across Finchley ABC didn't go
in there to be heavyweight world
champion went in there for some
direction some hope that family feeling
that a boxing gym gives you you know and
through it actually became Olympic
Champion and World Heavyweight Champion
but every fighter that we represent will
tell you the same story boxing changed
or boxing saved my life that goes across
all sports what do you feel about two
issues about sport right now one that at
school everyone gets a participation
prize even if they come last secondly
boys now race against girls which I
think is completely ridiculous many
schools have gone down this way unisex
sports day which I think is ridiculous
and then you have the the ongoing issue
of transgender athletes in sport
dominating biological females in women's
sport let's take the first one
let's take the last one first the
transgender issue what do you feel about
that as a sports promoter
I mean I'm you know I'm of the old
school mentality where you know of
course male athletes compete against
male athletes female athletes complete
against uh female athletes it's an
awkward conversation to have it's not
about a level plan when you talk about
physical Sports there is no way unboxing
is a great example we haven't had that
problem yet well if Mike Tyson suddenly
turn right I'm now Michelle Tyson and
I'm going to compete as a woman the
world would go completely crazy and say
you're going to kill somebody you're
going to kill a woman but we seemed
perfectly okay with six foot four inch
swimmers my biological males dominating
women
weightlifters bizarre shouldn't be
allowed and ultimately you know whoever
you upset you upset but not sport not
not not a fair sport not a fair race not
a Fair competition it's to me it's the
same as doping is it you're giving
yourself a physical advancement exactly
which of course can't be allowed kids
and participation prizes at school if
you come some love when I I mean I used
to win the non-finalist race on sports
day which was for all the losers but I
used to make sure I was the best loser
right because I wasn't an athlete my two
brothers used to win everything and my
sons have been very good at sports day
but I I wasn't but I remember the pain
of losing and I wanted to be the best
and he's the best loser but this idea
that if you come last you still get a
little prize because they can't be upset
this this mindset is where I think this
country is going so wrong yeah and I'm a
bad person to ask because I couldn't be
more on your side than on your page
winning
this is how I grew up winning is
everything right it's not it's the only
thing that matters whatever you do win
yes and that's the attitude we have in
sport in business doesn't matter if I'm
playing my old man over a game of table
tennis he's diving on the floor you know
it's absolute Do or Die Winning is
Everything I struggle having two
daughters especially and one is very
good at football and she'll get taken
off in matches because we have to give
everybody again
but it's so difficult you know I mean on
one stage we talk about the the
importance of sport yeah and we talk
about encouragement
you can't close the door to a young kid
no but you tell the young kid if you
want to be as bad as that kid here's
what you've got to do but at the same
time we we don't want to close don't
sacrifice your principles I will never
and and you know don't let them take
your daughter off my old man referred to
me recently as a project you know and
that that was like that's his thing you
know it's about winning and we have that
mentality what we must do is we must
continue to create winners because if
it's in sport if it's in business in
everything in life and you know
unfortunately now we live in a world
where everybody actually tries to bring
the winners down and deflate the winners
you know make sure they just for this
thing of having a school on sports day
boys competing with girls I think he's a
complete Madness complete Madness what
are you trying to do to these girls kill
their self-esteem tell them they're not
as good as boys simply because the boys
have a physical Advantage I think all of
it is wrong
I think completely wrong and also on the
winning argument ultimately kids need to
be told winning you know I used to come
home from a game of cricket my old man
would go to me how'd you get on I'll go
oh no we've got a good ball got four
useless right what's the matter with you
get there tomorrow and go knocking 100
right right and that was it that was
life you know that to me is about
teaching someone to to Aid to want to
compete properly why bother entering
anything that's competitive if you don't
want to win and why is winning such a
bad thing these days right nowadays
people who lose get celebrated if they
quit they get more celebrated even if
they compete but that's a classic
British trait isn't it we we really do
glorify our greatest losers or almost I
mean Frank Bruno is a great example was
one of the most popular you know
characters Sportsmen in this country won
a world heavyweight title actually
people sort of went ah he's won the
World Heavyweight time yeah it was like
a bit of a disappointment our friend who
couldn't really ever win a world
heavyweight title has won one I mean I
feel like Andy Murray suffers from that
a little bit yeah you know through his
success I mean Tim him and another
example good old Tim couldn't quite win
win Wimbledon we love him yeah you know
and that that sometimes the British
mentality we need to move more towards
educating young people that you know you
have to achieve you on your on your
cabinet in your office you have a school
board Eddie V Barry School Board boxing
skills it says one nil to Eddie you
obviously you beat him snooker skills
one nil to Barry he beats you at snooker
Instagram followers 62 Barry 1.2 million
Eddie Amazon book I love this Amazon
book reviews 33 Barry 1 370 for any hi
well obviously your daughter the name
golf handicap uh you're now beating him
so actually you're quite ahead now on
the metric but I'll tell you one very
quick story about my old man which the
book is the one right so I get asked to
write a book it's called Relentless it's
about you know my work ethic my love for
the business the sport all that kind of
stuff wrote it in three months with a
Ghostwriter during lockdown right he's
been writing his for nine or ten years
you know I won't want to embarrass him
but I made significantly more money for
my fee to write the book than he did but
what he said was what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take more money on
commission so I'm going to make more
money than you after the book was
written fantastic book took him six or
seven years to write the book it was I
must recommend he drove around the
country with books in the boot and was
knocking him out at events to try and
outsell me right I think I've done 60
000 he done eight thousand in Yen but
this is what I'm up against you know I
get the feeling though because you have
such a lovely relationship I've seen it
the first time and you're very similar
in many ways and he just wanted you to
be the best you could possibly be even
if that meant you were more successful
than him I don't think he really minded
that he just never wanted you to
shortchange yourself right he wanted you
to be the best competitive Beast that he
could possibly Empower you to be and he
wants me you know he wants to be a
graphic he wants to win and that's the
thing with business now you know we are
we he might say to me how'd you get on
it Dallas Cowboys you know how many
turned up to that Canelo fight you know
and he'll say well have you seen the
ratings for the darts smashed your box
in it's like that we're in the same
company you know but that's that but I'm
like this for my sons
he'll try and kill me yeah I mean but I
want nothing else I don't want them
giving me anything I want to give them
anything when I played table tennis with
my daughter who's 11 I want to beat her
so that when she finally beats me she
knows she beat me trying to beat her
that will mean so much more than if I
just let her win yeah that's exactly
what happens around my old man's house
on a Sunday
let just want to ask you quickly about
Connor bang because I interviewed him on
this this show he's one of your your
Fighters I gotta say I I ended that
interview really just not sure what to
believe but actually veering slightly I
felt in my gut that he might be telling
the truth that he has been the victim of
a miscarriage of Justice here over this
uh suggestive that he took illicit drugs
you believe in him why why are you so
convinced because I've known Connor Ben
since he was 18 19 years of age since he
came over from Australia on his own left
his mum and dad there to make a name for
himself in boxing the meticulous nature
of his preparation you know his love of
the sport
um you know he's deep Faith all of the
things the way he trains with Tony Sims
the closeness of their relationship the
way that he was so insistent on
additional testing that he paid for
going into this fight
and the amount of times that I've sat
with this young man in my office and
watched him break down in tears yeah he
did it on the floor and and for me to
question him I didn't believe him a
certainly you know because you've been
criticized because you've always ripped
into other cheating because you know
what in in this instance and in life in
general guilty until proven innocent my
first reaction was I can't believe it he
would like he wouldn't do that do you
believe you'll be exonerated I do and I
believe you know he went through the
right procedure with the WBC involver
that's who did the test he was cleared
he was reinstated in the rankings
everyone said oh he needs to go through
a ucad in a British boxing border
control he turned around he went okay
I'll do that as well he spent hundreds
of thousands going through that process
and the result is imminent and I believe
him and I've had it's one year since the
test every day I mean I've had loads of
stick he's had Untold and if he's
cleared which I believe he will be I
hope that some people under stand what
he went look at Kevin Spacey the actor
who today got found not guilty on all
these sex assault charges he's been
already convicted by the court of public
opinion on Twitter mercilessly called
the most horrendous things and today
he's come out an innocent man Twitter is
and social media generally it's an
unforgiving call that just prosecutes
people without seeing evidence and I
feel that a little bit about Conor
that'd be interesting to see what
happens on that before I let you go
how much are you worth me if you died
tomorrow
I don't know yes you do I don't know yes
you do anything no to the nearest table
I tell you what we're doing all right
but I'll work like I'm skinned every day
that's a good that's a good model and if
you were prime minister which many
people think you should be you couldn't
do them the worst job in the Tories have
done the last 10 years let's be honest
what's the first thing you do to fix
this country the first thing I would do
would be to increase participation in
sport for young Jew our young kids are
in a terrible terrible situation social
media disaster Twitter toxic you know
everybody that has ambition everybody
that has desire everybody that has a
strategy in their mind gets derailed by
negativity by people who can't do it all
you were saying I put a video out just
before we came over me and you right and
immediately in comes the abuse about
both of us right now we can handle it
we've got thick skins I think I say the
one quality I really have is great is
I've got an incredibly thick skin I just
watch this off to me most people I know
in the public eye find it really hard
but but you know we can say we've got a
thick skin which we have you have I have
but after waking up every morning it was
a great we said you know you wake up in
a great mood
what on Earth am I reading here what is
going on and that there's no point in
infiltrating yourself with negativity
Life's Too Short we can handle it kids
can't no that's the difference and
they've been bombarded with constant
negative stuff and the algorithms of
content which is ultimately designed to
feed the way they think yeah you see you
see girls who talking to each other
about self-harming next thing Tick Tock
is sending them loads of stuff total
it's feeding a horrible thing we and we
you know parents have to make sure that
you limit that time and we have to
educate the kids and I think the best
way to educate is through sport every
time you see a kid put down their fun I
agree and participate I agree with
energy with a smile on their face with a
desire to win and compete it's the
greatest thing to watch and whether it's
boxing which I'm a massive fan of or you
know the government need to make sure
that we keep the opportunities because
inner city schools just don't have a
sport they don't I went from a fee
paying prep school at 12 13 too
comprehensive and I went from playing
three hours of sport a day to nothing
once a week if someone can finally care
or a teacher just it's not good enough
this country has to do that I think
sport is the answer actually it's good
for well-being it's good for physical
the mental everything Eddie I could talk
to you all night and I felt your guns
earlier you did feel like a devil and in
fact you would say why are you not why
are you not competing I need I need your
I need your schedule thank you well you
may see my pin tweet on Twitter which is
Ronaldo telling me what great abs I've
got uh now he knows all about ABS Eddie
great to see you thank you come back
again I loved it I should do more I
really appreciate it and you're so right
about all of it thank you